Could you write a method that
downloads in the background and
then returns the image once it's done?
Try to write one, I'll wait.
No luck?
That's because it's impossible.
Let's see why.
When you call a function and
wait for it to return,
you're making an assumption you
probably never paid attention to.
You have seen the function
knows where to return.
This is fine in serial synchronous
code where the calling code
will be blocked until
the function returns.
In asynchronous code, however,
the calling code may continue
doing something else, therefore,
we need to provide the function,
with the information on what it
needs to do once it's finished.
In SWF, that information could be passed
in a closure, a completion closure.
You've seen many so
far, in Apple's code.
Now, you're going to write your own.
Yeah!